I think discovering for what I'll give
you a couple of examples so discovering
in an archive in Germany that the sum of
the German soldiers this was an archive
of war crimes investigators and it
contained case files of investigations
conducted by the police in the 1970s
about things that had happened in the
war that never came to trial so they've
been left there in the archives all
these interviews of these middle-aged
men being called into their local police
station you know after becoming middle
managers in the local factory or
wherever about what their donors boys in
an army unit in Greece in 1943 on August
of 15 and so I had started reading about
one case and I actually knew the village
I'd gone to the village and interviews
on the survivors were a lot of people
were killed and then finding and it
could have only found it in this kind of
material that actually these soldiers
had really had a terrific argument among
themselves on the way back about what
they've done
that was really interesting because it
it opened up or a kind of emphasize the
importance of doing a sort of
ethnography of the Nazi soldier you
couldn't assume you knew what they
thought because actually they disagreed
with themselves about all of this and
they'd had this huge argument in which
they tried to make sense of it so how
did the young National Socialists very
much soul to make sense of massive
violence that's an interesting kind of
question and that legend in a direction
I spent a lot of time I remember asking
my father how they felt at the end of
the war and he said well i think was we
all felt we're very glad of course we
all felt extremely tired and so that's
it you know that actually resonated with
me what was the kind of private public
into play war is by definition utterly
public but then so then you go back into
your private life and what do you take
with you and how does it shave the
private loads of things I mean work I
there's a little archive I work on in a
Greek island and it told me a story
about two villages and I often walk
through which are 100 yards apart
looking on the same valley where they
used to have stone-throwing Wars quite
serious stone Thrones and we're talking
about the 1820s what yeah who the hell
ever heard of stone-throwing what were
they about yeah right so you're all
always coming across this kind of thing
and does it help sue